Lucia:啊哎这也是牛奶
Lucia: Ah, hey, this is also milk.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia:那个好的
Lucia: That one is good.
Jake:我靠这已经是汤了
Jake: Damn, this is already soup.
Lucia:我放一下
Lucia: I'll put it here.
Lucia:sorry谢谢
Lucia: Sorry, thanks.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Jake:这冰淇淋这麦旋风
Jake: This ice cream, this McFlurry.
Jake:饮这汤呢有用吗
Jake: Does drinking this soup help?
其他人:有有有
Others: Yes, yes, yes.
Jake:那就动一下放到下面就行
Jake: Then just move it and put it underneath.
Alice:你放下边
Alice: Put it down there.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Okay.
Shure: 怎么了有只苍蝇掉进去了
Shure: What's up? A fly fell in.
其他人：有只苍蝇掉进去了
Others: A fly fell in.
Jake:我操哈哈
Jake: Damn, haha.
其他人：不是这个苍蝇朝着这就飞过来了
Others: No, the fly just flew over here.
其他人：然后就自己飞
Others: And then it flew away by itself.
Jake:哈呃自取灭亡
Jake: Ha, you're bringing about your own destruction.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure: 没事高蛋白
Shure: It's okay, high protein.
Jake:给给您吃哈哈
Jake: Here, have some, haha.
Shure: 这是油还是啊不能吃
Shure: Is this oil or...? I can't eat this.
Katrina: 啊我的我的我刚戴隐形眼镜
Katrina: Ah, mine, mine. I just put in contact lenses.
Shure: 哇谁这么奢侈
Shure: Wow, who’s so extravagant?
Shure: 点的安哥斯候牛宝
Shure: Ordered an Angus beef burger.
Lucia:哎呦喂sorry
Lucia: Oops, sorry.
Lucia:扔个垃圾先说
Lucia: Let me throw this trash first.
Tasha:之前说吃安格斯厚牛堡的都是渣女
Tasha: They say girls who eat Angus beef burgers are trashy.
Tasha:你是捞女是吧是吗
Tasha: Are you a gold digger?
Lucia:不好意思是吗
Lucia: Excuse me, am I?
其他人：是是
Others: Yes, yes.
Alice:有那个梗是吗对对对
Alice: There's that joke, right?
其他人：对对对
Others: Yes, yes.
其他人：男朋友我想吃安格斯牛堡
Others: Boyfriend, I want to eat an Angus beef burger.
Tasha:你个捞米
Tasha: You gold digger.
Shure: 是个捞女
Shure: She's a gold digger.
其他人：不能吃便宜的吗
Others: Can't you eat something cheaper?
其他人：搞这么贵
Others: Why so expensive?
其他人：这么物质
Others: So materialistic.
Jake:盲盒盲盒盲盒
Jake: Blind box, blind box, blind box.
Jake:还有谁没挑吗
Jake: Anyone hasn't picked yet?
Lucia:乱拆
Lucia: Randomly open.
Jake:谁有派吗
Jake: Who's got the pie?
Jake:派是怎么点的
Jake: How do you order the pie?
Tasha:派是我点
Tasha: I ordered the pie.
Tasha:我点了两个派
Tasha: I ordered two pies.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Great.
Tasha:给你一个
Tasha: I'll give you one.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:薯条薯条都是谁
Jake: Who got the fries?
Jake:薯条就分着吃吧
Jake: Let's share the fries.
Jake:但是没有地方放呢要不然
Jake: But there's no place to put them. Or...
Jake:怎么找不到呵呵呵呃OK OK
Jake: Can't find it, haha, OK OK.
Lucia:把这一挪
Lucia: Move this over.
其他人：这个这是我的吧
Others: Is this mine?
Lucia:嗯
Lucia: Mm.
Jake:哎呀呀呀好损失了8根
Jake: Oh no, lost 8 fries.
Lucia:对不起对不起
Lucia: Sorry, sorry.
Jake:麦当劳汉堡
Jake: McDonald's burger.
Jake:麦当劳薯条
Jake: McDonald's fries.
Katrina: 嗯好冷啊
Katrina: Hmm, it's so cold.
Jake:薯条这叫什么呀这叫
Jake: What do you call these fries?
Jake:薯条自由是吗
Jake: Fries freedom, right?
Lucia:番茄酱在哪个袋子里呢
Lucia: Which bag has the ketchup?
Lucia:才给这么点番茄酱
Lucia: They gave us so little ketchup.
Tasha:今天晚上怎么吃这么好
Tasha: Why are we having such a feast tonight?
Tasha:我们是要走路了吗
Tasha: Are we going for a walk?
Tasha:要上路了是吧
Tasha: Are we hitting the road?
Tasha:我说今天晚上怎么吃这么好吃
Tasha: I was wondering why we're eating so well tonight.
Tasha:要上路了
Tasha: We're hitting the road.
Katrina: 还有堡呢
Katrina: There's still a burger left.
Jake:呃还还有很多
Jake: Uh, there's still a lot.
Jake:也没有很多了
Jake: Well, not that much.
Jake:还有几个
Jake: Just a few left.
Lucia:为啥你是直接挤在上面的
Lucia: Why did you squeeze it directly on top?
Lucia:我以为是挤在旁边然后站的那种
Lucia: I thought you'd squeeze it on the side to dip.
Jake:哦OK那也行
Jake: Oh, OK, that works too.
Lucia:没事都行
Lucia: It's fine, whatever.
Lucia:无所谓了好
Lucia: Doesn't matter, alright.
Jake:好好挤旁边合理
Jake: Okay, squeezing it on the side is reasonable.
其他人:这个能吃了吗
Others: Can we eat this now?
Tasha: 这个不可以吃
Tasha: This can't be eaten yet.
Tasha:我们要摆盘呢
Tasha: We need to plate it first.
Tasha:OK OK杨老师
Tasha: OK, OK, Mr. Yang.
Tasha:嗯你能把桌子收一下
Tasha: Hmm, can you clear the table?
Tasha:把外面的所有台位吗
Tasha: All the tables outside?
Tasha:你能摆一下吗
Tasha: Can you set them up?
Jake:好
Jake: Sure.
Katrina: 还有一盒薯条
Katrina: There's another box of fries.
Lucia:居然这么多薯条
Lucia: So many fries!
Alice:薯条开会
Alice: Fries meeting.
Katrina: 哈哈薯条山
Katrina: Haha, fries mountain.
Katrina: 盐我都看到了
Katrina: I can see the salt.
其他人:卧槽
Others: Whoa!
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Alice:太搞笑了
Alice: That's hilarious.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Shure: 我要小开一个会了家人们
Shure: I need to have a quick meeting, everyone.
Jake:还有3个堡是谁的
Jake: Whose are the remaining 3 burgers?
Jake:有一个是我的
Jake: One of them is mine.
Jake:可能吧
Jake: Maybe.
Jake:这个可以开
Jake: This one can be opened.
Shure: 我要开个会
Shure: I need to have a meeting.
Jake:你关了吧
Jake: Turn it off.
Jake:你关了吧你开会
Jake: Turn it off and have your meeting.
Shure: 后面也不记录了
Shure: We won't record anything after this.
Jake:你再开嘛
Jake: You can start again.
Shure: 再拍吧
Shure: Let's shoot again.
Shure: 也也行
Shure: That works too.
其他人:我靠我草
Others: Oh my god!
其他人:感动死我了
Others: I'm so touched!
Jake:我嗨了啊
Jake: I'm so hyped!
Jake:我嗨了呃开会
Jake: I'm so hyped... having a meeting.
其他人:呃开会
Others: ...having a meeting.
Lucia:这个拆开放这可以蘸
Lucia: If you open this, you can dip it.
其他人:他刚让我妈拆开一个bug
Others: He just asked my mom to open a bug.
其他人:他要他来一个我写bug
Others: He wants to write a bug himself.
其他人:哎怎么这么多厚图包
Others: Why are there so many thick packages?
Jake:盲盒盲盒
Jake: Blind boxes, blind boxes.
Katrina: 凤牛堡还有不一样的吗
Katrina: Are there different versions of Feng Niu burgers?
Lucia:啊不好意思
Lucia: Oh, sorry.
其他人:你想想你当时点的那个
Others: Think about what you ordered at that time.
其他人:我点的我点的应该是培根
Others: What I ordered should be bacon.
其他人:啊培根
Others: Ah, bacon.
其他人:那可能我给你吃了
Others: Maybe I ate yours.
Tasha:哇
Tasha: Wow.
其他人:但我记得我点的培根
Others: But I remember ordering bacon.
其他人:怎么还开火了
Others: Why is there a fire?
其他人:牛排是不是刘太监的
Others: Is the steak for Liu the Eunuch?
其他人:不好意思
Others: Sorry.
Jake:我我我
Jake: Me, me, me.
Jake:我看看怎么收拾
Jake: Let me see how to clean this up.
Jake:是这种吗
Jake: Is it like this?
Jake:是一样的
Jake: It's the same.
Jake:这个丢掉哈
Jake: Throw this away.
Jake:丢掉吗丢掉
Jake: Throw it away, throw it away.
Tasha:丢掉
Tasha: Throw it away.
Lucia:案板
Lucia: Cutting board.
Tasha:这你刚吃的芒果菠萝是吗
Tasha: Did you just eat mango and pineapple?
Jake:这有差别吗
Jake: Is there a difference?
其他人:今天中午吃汉堡晚上吃麦当劳
Others: Had burgers for lunch, and McDonald's for dinner.
Alice:还有垃圾吗
Alice: Any more trash?
Jake:有垃圾袋
Jake: There's a trash bag.
Jake:这边有垃圾袋
Jake: There's a trash bag here.
Alice:这个
Alice: This one.
Lucia:这我的还没吃完
Lucia: I haven't finished mine yet.
Jake:鸡块没了
Jake: The chicken nuggets are gone.
Jake:哈哈是吧
Jake: Haha, right?
其他人:吃麦当劳为什么不需要蘸酱
Others: Why don't you need sauce for McDonald's?
其他人:我说话没有精盐味
Others: I don't speak with a salt accent.
其他人:味道不纯
Others: The taste isn't pure.
其他人:但
Others: But
其他人:我确实很好的融入了北京的社会环境
Others: I've really integrated well into Beijing's social environment.
其他人:不热爱挤地铁
Others: I don't enjoy squeezing into the subway.
其他人:真的
Others: Really.
其他人:我在北京上海实习之后我喜欢上海
Others: After interning in Beijing and Shanghai, I prefer Shanghai.
其他人:最重要一点就是
Others: The most important thing is
其他人:因为我在上海打车便宜
Others: because taking taxis in Shanghai is cheaper.
其他人:因为上海最省
Others: Because Shanghai is more affordable.
其他人：你这个时候应该给你给他找点盐
Others: You should get him some salt at this point.
Alice:那不是吗
Alice: Isn't that right?
Alice:那不是盐吗
Alice: Isn't that salt?
Alice:那个那个
Alice: That one, that one.
Jake:开摆
Jake: Let's do it.
Jake:开摆开摆
Jake: Let's do it, let's do it.
Katrina: 这洗了吗
Katrina: Has this been washed?
Lucia:厨房纸
Lucia: Kitchen paper.
Alice:哈哈等一下拍你你要摆一下吗
Alice: Haha, wait, do you need to pose for a picture?
Lucia:这个
Lucia: This one.
Lucia:就可以用这个吗
Lucia: Can we use this one?
Lucia:不能只能用那那个那种纸吗
Lucia: Can't we only use that kind of paper?
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha.
Jake:哼
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia:湿纸巾湿纸巾
Lucia: Wet wipes, wet wipes.
Jake:撒盐啊或者餐巾纸加水也行
Jake: Sprinkle salt or just use a napkin with some water.
Alice:笑死我了
Alice: You're killing me with laughter.
Jake:撒一个撒一个
Jake: Sprinkle some, sprinkle some.
Lucia:要不拿那个
Lucia: How about we take that?
Jake:撒了吧你
Jake: Just sprinkle it.
Jake:还没撒呢
Jake: I haven't sprinkled it yet.
Lucia:拿这个加水好了
Lucia: Let's add water with this.
Alice:撒过了
Alice: It's already sprinkled.
Lucia:哇
Lucia: Wow.
其他人:这个这个直接装盘吗
Others: Should we just put this directly on the plate?
Lucia:哇看起来好好吃
Lucia: Wow, it looks so delicious.
Lucia:好好看啊
Lucia: It's so beautiful.
Lucia:如果我们害怕他太腥了的话也
Lucia: If we're afraid it's too fishy...
Lucia:是不是可以给底下铺一层那个
Lucia: Should we put a layer of...
Lucia:那个那个叫什么
Lucia: What's that called?
Lucia:油纸还是烘焙纸那种纸
Lucia: Parchment paper or baking paper?
Lucia:因为感觉这个刚拆开的话
Lucia: Because when you just open it...
Lucia:不知道他有一些味什么的
Lucia: You don't know if it has a certain smell.
Lucia:散散散完了没有
Lucia: Is it dispersed yet?
Lucia:对要不就铺一个那个对在最底下有
Lucia: Yeah, maybe put a layer at the bottom.
Alice:铺一下那个油纸吧
Alice: Let's put some parchment paper.
Katrina: 有油纸吗
Katrina: Do we have parchment paper?
Katrina: 这是在为明天做准备吗
Katrina: Is this for preparing for tomorrow?
Lucia:应该是吧
Lucia: Probably.
其他人:感觉动作不太对
Others: Feels like the movements are not right.
Lucia:对他这个是有一点颜色还会
Lucia: Yes, it has a bit of color and...
Lucia:如果一用水一擦还会掉一些
Lucia: If you wipe it with water, some color might come off.
Alice:铺吗
Alice: Should we lay it?
Alice:那我搁那了
Alice: I'll put it there then.
其他人:真的刘帅
Others: Really, Choiszt.
其他人:我要是女生我嫁
Others: If I were a girl, I would marry.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Lucia:吃一个哦
Lucia: Have a bite.
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah.
Jake:嗯好吃
Jake: Hmm, delicious.
Jake:确实可以确实可以
Jake: It's really good, it really is.
Lucia:哇
Lucia: Wow.
Jake:确实很可以
Jake: It's really good.
Lucia:啊
Lucia: Ah.
其他人:凑巧做做成了一次
Others: Just happened to get it right this time.
其他人:有没有非常的谦虚啊
Others: Aren't you very humble?
其他人:如果我是一个女生
Others: If I were a girl...
其他人:我就非常喜欢谦虚的男人
Others: I would really like a humble man.
其他人:哈哈哈哈
Others: Hahaha
Katrina: 你的掩盖不了你爱上他的事实
Katrina: You can't hide the fact that you're in love with him.
其他人:我自从有一次点了麦当劳的牛奶
Others: Ever since I ordered McDonald's milk once,
其他人:麦当劳的牛奶非常的牛
Others: McDonald's milk is amazing.
Shure: 嗯大家可以听见我说话吗
Shure: Um, can everyone hear me?
Shure: OK OK
Shure: 然后嗯
Shure: And then, um,
Shure: 这次百花节的话是在沙河校区
Shure: This year's Baihua Festival will be at the Shahe campus.
Shure: 然后呢
Shure: And then,
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Um,
Shure: 舞台给我们
Shure: The stage for us,
Shure: 可能就是大概三三四首歌曲这样的
Shure: is probably for about three or four songs.
其他人:哈哈哈时间管理大师
Others: Hahaha, master of time management.
Shure: 一个一个
Shure: One by one,
Shure: 一个一个时间
Shure: One by one, the time.
Shure: 嗯大概是是这样的一个时长
Shure: Um, that's roughly the duration.
Shure: 然后这是第一个事情就是节目的事情
Shure: And then, the first thing is about the program.
Shure: 然后还有一个事情就是嗯
Shure: And another thing is, um,
Shure: 嗯就是就是那个需要运输设备的话
Shure: Um, it's about the equipment transportation.
Shure: 这边是给提供货拉拉的
Shure: Here we will provide Huolala services.
Shure: 然后需要统计一下需要运输的设备
Shure: We need to tally the equipment to be transported.
Shure: 但是呃音箱什么的其实沙河那边就有
Shure: But actually, the Shahe campus already has speakers and such.
Shure: 所以我感觉咱们的设备什么的
Shure: So I feel like our equipment
Shure: 就可以跟他们呃一起用
Shure: can be used together with theirs.
Shure: 这个运输设备上
Shure: For the transportation of equipment,
Shure: 就就应该不需要呃太多
Shure: we probably don't need too much.
Shure: 要要要要运过去的东西
Shure: We don't need to transport too much stuff.
Shure: 然后这个关于百花节
Shure: Then, about the Baihua Festival,
Shure: 呃还有一点
Shure: there's one more thing.
Shure: 就是因为还会涉及到那个摆摊嘛
Shure: There will be stalls involved,
Shure: 然后咱们就摆摊的活动需要想一下
Shure: so we need to think about the stall activities.
Shure: 嗯大概就这三个事情
Shure: Um, that's about the three things.
Shure: 就是关于百花节的
Shure: related to the Baihua Festival.
Shure: 抱歉今天那个哎
Shure: Sorry, today, um,
Shure: 刚刚突然来了点事情
Shure: something suddenly came up.
Shure: 然后就一下忙忘了
Shure: and I got busy and forgot.
Shure: 实在抱歉
Shure: Really sorry.
Jake:哎人呢
Jake: Hey, where is everyone?
Shure: 哎呦
Shure: Oh no.
Jake:开会啊
Jake: Meeting time?
Shure: 然后
Shure: Then...
Shure: 大家看看
Shure: Everyone take a look.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey...
Shure: 怎么怎么搞一下这个
Shure: How do we handle this?
Shure: 首先先解决一下节目这个事情吧
Shure: First, let's solve the show issue.
Shure: 就是节目需要
Shure: It's just that the show needs...
Shure: 还还需要还需要审查
Shure: It still needs to be reviewed.
Shure: 这是最麻烦的
Shure: That's the most troublesome part.
Shure: 因为大家可能
Shure: Because everyone might...
Shure: 咱们这边都是以本部为主的
Shure: We are mainly focused on our headquarters.
Shure: 就是26号到27号还要去沙河那边审查
Shure: On the 26th to 27th, we still have to go to Shahe for the review.
Shure: 2627是周几
Shure: What days are the 26th and 27th?
Shure: 周五和周六
Shure: Friday and Saturday.
Jake:走现在走
Jake: Let's go now.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm...
Jake:呵呵呵没有没有没有取消了
Jake: Haha, no, no, no, it's canceled.
Shure: 然后要不咱们就先做一个问卷吧
Shure: Then, why don't we make a questionnaire first?
Shure: 然后就是想报名的
Shure: And those who want to sign up...
Shure: 在在那个就是负责人那个群里发一下
Shure: Can post in the group of the person in charge.
Shure: 然后想报名的就填一下
Shure: And those who want to sign up, just fill it out.
其他人:我跟你讲
Other: Let me tell you.
Shure: 然后咱们再筛筛
Shure: Then we'll screen...
其他人:你去海淀黄庄门口
Other: You go to Haidian Huangzhuang gate.
Shure: 选一下这个那个队伍和节目
Shure: Select the team and the show.
Shure: 然后把这个审查的信息都告诉他们
Shure: Then inform them all about the review details.
Shure: 然后大概就是这个样子
Shure: And that's basically it.
Shure: 所以
Shure: So...
Shure: 现在需要一个同学来做一份这个问卷
Shure: Now we need a student to make the questionnaire.
Shure: 哪位同学可以做一下
Shure: Which student can do it?
其他人:你的孩子
Other: Your child...
其他人:将来有可能会出现在我们的论文里面
Other: Might appear in our thesis in the future.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm...
其他人:我们是做AI的
Other: We're working on AI.
其他人:你知道我们女子今年开始的高峰赛道
Other: You know our women's peak season starts this year.
Shure: 啊好的
Shure: Ah, okay.
Shure: 萧逸同学首当其冲
Shure: Classmate Xiao Yi is at the forefront.
其他人::你不想想你的孩子不能输在起跑
Other: Don't you think your child can't lose at the starting line?
其他人:孩子升到初中正好结婚
Other: When your child moves up to middle school, they get married.
Shure: 那就
Shure: Then...
其他人:是开初中赛道了
Other: It's the start of middle school track.
其他人:对
Others: Yeah
其他人:海淀皇上那味可抽
Others: The Haidian Emperor's style is enjoyable
其他人:我操我知道海淀皇上初中
Others: Damn, I know the Haidian Emperor from middle school
其他人:哈哈哈
Others: Hahaha
Shure: 啊不是周日截止
Shure: Ah, isn't the deadline on Sunday?
Shure: 周日晚上24点截止
Shure: The deadline is Sunday night at 24:00
Shure: 这个收集
Shure: For this collection
Shure: 然后审查的话
Shure: And the review
Shure: 是在26号到226号和27号两天
Shure: Will be on the 26th and 27th
Shure: 然后演的话不是百花节是5月15号吧
Shure: And the performance is not during the Hundred Flowers Festival, but on May 15th, right?
Shure: 我我记得是吧嗯
Shure: I remember it that way, yeah
其他人:感觉我跟他们人大富人接触一下
Others: I feel like I should get in touch with those influential people
其他人:他们人大富人确实挺厉害的
Others: They're really impressive
其他人:哎你
Others: Hey, you
其他人:你身上有有人大富人吗
Others: Do you have any influential people around you?
其他人:有叫啥
Shure: 哦也是
Shure: Oh, right
Shure: 对对对对那
Shure: Yeah, yeah, that's it
Shure: 录录个视频嗯OK OK
Shure: Let's record a video, okay, okay
其他人:是不
Others: Right?
Shure: 好的好的
Shure: Got it, got it
Shure: 那我问一下这个事情
Shure: So let me ask about this
其他人:是
Others: Yes
Shure: 然后
Shure: Then
其他人:对
Others: Yeah
其他人:非常的非常的夸张
Others: It's really, really exaggerated
其他人:这
Others: This
其他人:我之前是参加此期实践的时候认识的
Others: I met them during a previous practice session
Shure: 行那你就先做一个问卷
Shure: Okay, then you can start with a questionnaire
Shure: 统计一下想报名参加的那个队伍吧
Shure: To see who wants to sign up for the team
Shure: 就是本部
Shure: Whether it's on the main campus
Shure: 要不在沙河
Shure: Or in Shahe
Shure: 呃地点
Shure: Uh, location
Shure: 时间然后先告诉一下
Shure: Time, and let them know first
Shure: 然后是
Shure: Then
Shure: 刚发的这个
Shure: The one we just sent
Shure: 就是这个事情
Shure: It's about this matter
Jake:这可以别人也开吗
Jake: Can others also start this?
Shure: 好好看来大家最近都都都懵懵的
Shure: Okay, it seems like everyone's been a bit confused lately
Shure: 然后我刚才说第二个事是啥来着啊
Shure: And then, what was the second thing I mentioned earlier?
Shure: 搬设备搬设备的话应该
Shure: Moving the equipment, moving the equipment should be...
Shure: 没什么太需要办的
Shure: There isn't much we need to do.
Shure: 对就借用那边
Shure: Yeah, we'll just borrow from over there.
其他人:心或者林展购物中心玩耍
Others: Have fun at Xin or Linzhan Shopping Center.
Shure: 摊位
Shure: The booth.
其他人:丝毫没有
Others: Not at all.
其他人:体会到海边王岛的危险的地方
Others: Didn't feel any danger at Haibian Wangdao.
Shure: 啊他说的是节目给的时间是
Shure: Ah, he said the time given by the program is...
其他人:两点半
Others: Two thirty.
Shure: 一个节目最好不超过5分钟
Shure: A show should not exceed 5 minutes.
Shure: 如果有优质活动想额外多报一些
Shure: If there are quality activities that want to report more...
Shure: 我们看能不能满足再决定
Shure: We'll see if we can accommodate and then decide.
Jake:白吃白喝
Jake: Free food and drinks.
Jake:就是白吃白喝
Jake: Just free food and drinks.
其他人:免费接送加白吃白喝嗯
Others: Free transportation plus free food and drinks, yeah.
Shure: 是一个舞台
Shure: It's a stage.
Shure: 就是在那个舞台上演
Shure: It's a performance on that stage.
Shure: 嗯就是
Shure: Yeah, it's just...
Shure: 记得二二维码广场那个那个演
Shure: Remember that performance at the QR Code Plaza?
Shure: 啊对
Shure: Ah, right.
Shure: 想起来了吧嗯嗯
Shure: You remember now, right? Yeah.
Shure: 对在沙河
Shure: Yeah, at Shahe.
Shure: 所以我突突然发现这个
Shure: So I suddenly realized that...
Shure: 拉人的话
Shure: As for attracting people...
Shure: 啊有有有有
Shure: Ah, there is, there is...
其他人:地铁站到那个接驳车
Others: Shuttle bus from the subway station.
其他人:大概半个小时一趟
Others: About once every half hour.
其他人:还是来过一次哈哈哈
Others: Still came once, hahaha.
Lucia:哈哈其他人:
Lucia: Hahaha, others:
Shure: 舞台有的舞台有的
Shure: There is a stage, there is a stage.
其他人:哦他可以不按照那个路
Others: Oh, he doesn't have to follow that route.
其他人:所以我不是接驳车吗
Others: So it's not a shuttle bus?
Shure: 呃啊对因为舞台的设备那边都有
Shure: Uh, yeah, because the stage equipment is all there.
Shure: 然后再加上什么鼓什么的
Shure: Plus, the drums and everything.
Shure: 沙河那边也都有
Shure: Shahe has everything too.
Shure: 所以就应该不用咱们操心
Shure: So we don't have to worry about it.
Shure: 对咱们摊位上想想
Shure: Yeah, let's think about our booth.
Shure: 对然后
Shure: Yeah, and...
Shure: 他这也不用审
Shure: There's no need for approval here either.
Shure: 这个就是自
Shure: This is just
Shure: 对这就是哎
Shure: Right, this is... oh
Shure: 摊位这种就是香果再加上吉他
Shure: A booth like this, with scented fruits and a guitar
Shure: 再加上一个话筒
Shure: Plus a microphone
Shure: 嗯对再拿拿音响
Shure: Yeah, right, and get some speakers
Shure: 哦这个那咱们就报一个音响吧
Shure: Oh, let's just report one speaker then
Shure: 就是报一个那个q吧还是哪个来着
Shure: Report that Q one, or which one was it?
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah
Jake:麦当劳
Jake: McDonald's
Shure: 嗯对拿两个就就可以
Shure: Yeah, right, just take two, that's fine
Shure: 嗯再再太大声
Shure: Hmm, too loud
Shure: 我估计别别的地方也会找
Shure: I guess other places will look for it too
Shure: 所以说这个牌然后再就是
Shure: So, this sign, and then
Shure: 哎这个百花的策划应该是得写的
Shure: Oh, the planning for the Baihua event should be written
Shure: 我记得
Shure: I remember
Shure: 去年有
Shure: There was one last year
Shure: 对我一会找一下这个然后弄一下
Shure: Yeah, I'll find that and handle it
Shure: 然后就想想活的活动都有什么活动
Shure: Then think about what activities we'll have
Shure: 就还是那些
Shure: Just the usual ones
Shure: OK OK
Shure: OK OK我感觉咱们这边是不是都是
Shure: OK OK, I feel like on our side, aren't they all
Shure: 老这叫什么人老登空的疼哈哈
Shure: What do you call them, old hands? Haha
Shure: 确实
Shure: Indeed
Jake:每天一公斤糖
Jake: One kilogram of sugar every day
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah
Shure: OK OK那就还是去年的那样的游戏
Shure: OK OK, then just like last year's games
Shure: 周五和周六两天
Shure: Friday and Saturday, two days
Shure: 对然后我问一下因为那个不方便
Shure: Yeah, then I'll ask around because it's inconvenient
其他人:最高评价
Other: Highest rating
Shure: 嗯然后这个的话就没什么然后
Shure: Hmm, then there's nothing much, and then
Shure: 上次那个谁
Shure: Last time, who was it
Shure: 咱们不是还想办一次专场吗
Shure: Didn't we want to organize a special event?
Shure: 这今年
Shure: This year
Shure: 然后就是想着
Shure: And we were thinking
Tasha:是的会喷的
Tasha: Yes, it's going to spray
其他人:或者提拉米苏就更像
Other: Or tiramisu would be more like it
Tasha:拿个刮刀能把它抹平吗
Tasha: Can we smooth it with a scraper?
Tasha:有没有一个刮刀
Tasha: Do we have a scraper?
Shure: 哎呀想着啥呢
Shure: Oh, what are you thinking about?
Shure: 摇滚夜那个
Shure: Rock night
Shure: 那个怎么怎么办呢
Shure: So, what should we do about that?
Lucia:小的那个刚没找着
Lucia: I couldn't find the smaller one just now.
Shure: 这个
Shure: This one.
Shure: 没没跟老师聊过
Shure: I haven't talked to the teacher yet.
Shure: 咱们先内部讨论一下
Shure: Let's discuss it internally first.
Shure: 首先第一点就是本部科会对吧
Shure: The first point is the department meeting, right?
Shure: 啊对科会或学活
Shure: Yeah, the department meeting or student activities.
Shure: 哎但是去年学活有点有点low
Shure: But last year's student activities were a bit low-key.
Shure: 就是大家好像
Shure: Like, everyone seemed...
Shure: 站着听的欲望不是特别特别大
Shure: Not very interested in standing and listening.
Shure: 而且那四个音箱说实话
Shure: And honestly, those four speakers...
Shure: 四面八方来生就很奇怪有点
Shure: The sound coming from all directions was kind of weird.
Shure: 确实去年没给钱
Shure: We didn't pay last year, indeed.
其他人:这为什么这么稀呀
Others: Why is it so sparse?
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Shure: 啊好了好对然后
Shure: Ah, alright, good, then...
Shure: 对然后这个的话是可以可以
Shure: Yes, and this one, where can it be...
Shure: 在可以在哪呢
Shure: Where can it be?
Shure: 就是可以在学活
Shure: Like, it can be at the student activities...
Shure: 或者刻绘是不是也可以
Shure: Or can it be at the department meeting too?
Alice:这个应该快没那个存储了
Alice: This one is almost out of storage.
Alice:停吗
Alice: Should we stop?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure: 那这个是不是跟去年就形式有点
Shure: So, isn't this format a bit...
Shure: 有点类似了
Shure: A bit similar to last year's?
Alice:3333
Alice: 3333
Shure: 行你问一下小雨那边能不能行
Shure: Alright, ask Rain if that's okay.
Shure: 然后这个
Shure: And then this...
Shure: 这个策划就也跟去年那个策划
Shure: This plan is pretty much the same as last year's.
Shure: 其实就差不多都一样
Shure: Right?
Shure: 是吧
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 然后我主要看一眼
Shure: I'll mainly check...
Shure: 具体什么时候有那个时间
Shure: Exactly when we have the time.
Lucia:他蛋挞底下是有那个没有
Lucia: Is there anything under the egg tart?
Lucia:没有啊嗯
Lucia: No? Hmm.
Lucia:因为那个刚拆开
Lucia: Because it was just opened.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 但是去年的时候大家就基本都没没
Shure: But last year, people basically didn't...
Shure: 没什么人愿意站
Shure: Not many people wanted to stand.
Shure: 就是看完自己的亲友那个就就回去了
Shure: They just left after watching their friends and family.
Shure: 你知道吧
Shure: You know, right?
Shure: 就是会出现对
Shure: It's just that it will appear, right?
Shure: 嗯也行对不行那后台摆凳子
Shure: Hmm, it's okay. If it's not okay, we can place some chairs backstage.
其他人:他明天不来吗
Others: Is he not coming tomorrow?
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Shure: OK
Shure: OK.
Shure: 分区卖票是吧
Shure: So we're selling tickets by section, right?
Shure: 这样半夜会被骂的哦
Shure: If we do this, we'll get scolded in the middle of the night.
Shure: 好好好
Shure: Alright, alright, alright.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey.
Shure: 室外场地的话咱们有有可能
Shure: If it's an outdoor venue, we might have a chance.
Shure: 我意思就是就是就是就是
Shure: What I mean is, like, like, like, like...
Shure: 那个去那种什么Livehouse之类的
Shure: Going to one of those Livehouses or something.
Shure: 是不是审审批上会非常的麻烦
Shure: Wouldn't getting approval for that be extremely troublesome?
Shure: 而且咱们没有办法来回这个本是吧
Shure: And we wouldn't be able to recoup the costs, right?
Tasha:你可以把黄豆粉拿来
Tasha: Can you bring the soybean powder?
Jake:土豆粉
Jake: Potato starch.
Alice:黄豆粉
Alice: Soybean powder.
Shure: 确实
Shure: Indeed.
Shure: 呃
Shure: Uh...
Alice:你要玩吗
Alice: Do you want to play?
Lucia:这边这个比较齐
Lucia: This side is more complete.
其他人:卧槽你看
Others: Whoa, look at that.
Shure: 是啊
Shure: Yeah.
其他人:对哼
Others: Right, humph.
Shure: 一年一度最最有意义的
Shure: The most meaningful annual event.
Shure: 反响最好的一个活动
Shure: The one with the best response.
Shure: 哦哦现在这包里还装着那个票
Shure: Oh, oh, there's still that ticket in this bag.
Shure: 那个青春筑梦百年百花那个入场券
Shure: The "Youth Dream Building Century Bloom" admission ticket.
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Shure: 哈
Shure: Ha.
Shure: 啊可以可以
Shure: Ah, okay, okay.
其他人:我靠高级
Others: Wow, fancy.
Shure: 确实
Shure: Indeed.
其他人：非常实厉害
Others: Very impressive.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Mm-hmm.
Shure: 对
Shure: Right.
Shure: 确实
Shure: Indeed.
Jake:那我现在鼠标上吧
Jake: Then I'll go with the mouse now.
Lucia:抹茶粉太贵了
Lucia: Matcha powder is too expensive.
Shure: 工工工作
Shure: Wo-wo-working
Shure: 在在在上班的时候
Shure: When-whe-when I'm at work
Shure: 我靠认识好多那个
Shure: I got to know a lot of those
Shure: 就是最开始办这这些活动的那些学长
Shure: The seniors who first organized these events
Tasha:我靠真的好吃
Tasha: Wow, it's really delicious
Shure: 他们非常的有这个意愿看到这个事情
Shure: They were very eager to see this happen
Shure: 你知道吧对
Shure: You know, right
Shure: 这谁准备吃海底捞了是吗
Shure: Is someone about to eat at Haidilao?
Shure: 啊啊香香阁啊
Shure: Ah, Xiangxiangge
Shure: 好的好的
Shure: Okay, okay
Shure: 大概
Shure: Probably
Tasha:呃一克一克两块钱
Tasha: Uh, two bucks for one gram
Shure: 大概就是这两两个事情
Shure: It's basically these two things
Shure: 一个是百花的事情
Shure: One is the Baihua thing
Shure: 一个是那什么的事情
Shure: The other is that whatever thing
Tasha:那便宜好多
Tasha: That's much cheaper
Shure: 对设备的话
Shure: Yeah, for the equipment
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah
Shure: 如果那个能用的话那就会省一大笔钱
Shure: If that can be used, it'll save a lot of money
Shure: 就是几乎就没有没
Shure: Almost no expenses
Shure: 有开销了
Shure: No expenses at all
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed
Shure: 行
Shure: Alright
Shure: 那我去催爆米吧
Shure: I'll go check on the popcorn
Tasha:边角料全部都炫掉
Tasha: Eat up all the scraps
Tasha:哎嗯
Tasha: Yeah, uh-huh
Shure: 好我们我我再拉个
Shure: Alright, I'll set up a
Shure: 拉个那种小群吧你就哎
Shure: A small group, you know
Shure: 沙游集的社
Shure: For the club
Shure: 现在社长是谁你知道吗
Shure: Do you know who's the president now?
其他人:我靠那一会没撒完
Others: Wow, that didn't sprinkle all over
其他人:抹茶粉可以炫耀谁
Others: Who can show off matcha powder?
其他人:我很喜欢的
Others: I really like it
Shure: 啊谷谷雨辰是吗啊OK
Shure: Ah, Gu Yuchen, right? Ah, OK
Shure: 我知道我知道嗯是
Shure: I know, I know, yeah
Shure: 谷雨辰
Shure: Gu Yuchen
Shure: 啊古古雨辰网名叫啥来着哈哈
Shure: Ah, Gu Yuchen, what's his username again? Haha
其他人:我靠
Others: Wow
其他人:非常的高级
Others: Very classy
Shure: 好吧我一会找一下嗯找
Shure: Alright, I'll look it up later, yeah
Tasha:对
Tasha: Yes.
Shure: 啊OK
Shure: Ah, OK.
Shure: POLAR啊找到了找到了
Shure: POLAR, I found it, I found it.
Shure: OK然后再需
Shure: OK, then we need...
Lucia:你想吃哪个吃哪个
Lucia: Eat whichever one you want.
Shure: 行那就应该没别的事就先把那个表呃
Shure: Alright, that should be it. Let's just get that table, uh...
Shure: 那个那个那什么给创一下
Shure: That thing, let's create it.
Shure: 对问卷
Shure: Yeah, the questionnaire.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Shure: OK
Shure: OK.
Shure: 摊位摊位的节目的话对
Shure: For the booth programs, right.
Shure: 对对对可以然后不好的就不插电
Shure: Yeah, yeah, yeah, we can. If it's not good, we won't plug it in.
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Shure: 好的
Shure: Got it.
Tasha:因为本来是吸的
Tasha: Because it was supposed to be sucked.
Tasha:但是这个蛋挞太热了给它融了
Tasha: But the egg tart was too hot and it melted.
Shure: 嗯好
Shure: Hmm, okay.
Katrina: 好哈哈哈
Katrina: Alright, hahaha.
Katrina: 这很这很舒服
Katrina: This feels, this feels so good.
Katrina: 这跟这一个系列的
Katrina: It's part of the series.
Tasha:快吃快吃
Tasha: Eat quickly, eat quickly.
Tasha:别拍了
Tasha: Stop filming.
Tasha:大家快吃
Tasha: Everybody, eat quickly.
Katrina: 应该都是这种
Katrina: They should all be like this.
Katrina: 然后还有一个
Katrina: And then there's another one.
Shure: 行那我就先报上一个
Shure: Okay, then I'll report this one first.
Shure: 他他应该给我记得
Shure: He, he should remember it.
Jake:来吃吃吃
Jake: Come on, eat, eat, eat.
Shure: 不是不是小程消息消息
Shure: No, no, Xiao Cheng, the message, the message.
Jake:大师您先吃您先吃
Jake: Master, you eat first, you eat first.
Tasha:您先吃
Tasha: You eat first.
Jake:您先吃下一个
Jake: You eat first, next one.
Jake:哈哈哎
Jake: Haha, hey.
Tasha:哎这个真的擦了吗
Tasha: Hey, did you really wipe this?
Lucia:擦了但是他那个渣就会粘在上面
Lucia: I did, but the crumbs will stick to it.
Shure: 那我这么写
Shure: Then I'll write it like this.
Lucia:挂掉
Lucia: Hang up.
Tasha:嗯嗯嗯
Tasha: Hmm, hmm, hmm.
Lucia:所以我那那里面也垫一个
Lucia: So I'll put another one inside.
Shure: 音乐社对因为今天没有
Shure: The music club, yeah, because today we don't have...
Shure: 晚上他说没有
Shure: He said no last night.
Shure: 没有灯光咱们怎么米越来越少
Shure: Without lights, how come our rice is decreasing?
Shure: 现在连灯光的米都没了是吗
Shure: Now we even don't have rice for lighting, right?
Lucia:那就垫一下吧
Lucia: Then just pad it up.
Lucia:因为我擦的时候
Lucia: Because when I was wiping it,
Lucia:感觉他真的有点有点掉色
Lucia: I felt like it was losing some color.
Katrina: 这个很舒服
Katrina: This is very comfortable.
其他人:傻逼企鹅狗都别买
Others: Don't buy stupid penguin dogs.
Shure: 我现在跟他们要
Shure: I'll ask them now.
其他人:没事我买这个
Others: It's okay, I'll buy this one.
Shure: 要30分钟
Shure: It'll take 30 minutes.
Katrina: 企鹅坏人
Katrina: Penguins are bad guys.
Shure: 可能抱去那什么了吧
Shure: Maybe they took it away or something.
Katrina: 哎呀哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Oh, hahaha.
Shure: 抱去那个开运动会了吧
Shure: Maybe they took it for the sports meet.
Shure: 行没什么其他事嗯
Shure: Alright, nothing else, right?
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Katrina: 一般是个人海淘
Katrina: Usually it's personal overseas shopping.
Jake:我先把这个收了吧
Jake: Let me pack this up first.
Katrina: 就是他们从官网下单
Katrina: They order directly from the official site.
Katrina: 然后要等一个月什么的
Katrina: And then have to wait a month or so.
Katrina: 然后这种的话就比较真
Katrina: So these ones are more authentic.
Katrina: 要么就官网买
Katrina: Or buy from the official site.
Katrina: 官网经常没货
Katrina: But the official site often runs out of stock.
Katrina: 像这种小11
Katrina: For these small ones like 11,
Katrina: 你看这种
Katrina: Look at this.
Katrina: 这种系列就很性价比不高
Katrina: This series is not cost-effective.
Katrina: 你看160一个
Katrina: Look, one costs 160.
Katrina: 这个就这么大
Katrina: And it's only this big.
Katrina: 你知道吗
Katrina: You know?
Tasha:咖啡液咖啡液
Tasha: Coffee liquid, coffee liquid.
Tasha:你切
Tasha: You cut it.
Tasha:但是你可以用那个切刀洗咖啡液
Tasha: But you can use that cutter to wash the coffee liquid.
Lucia:是咱们那天那个绿色的那个吗
Lucia: Is it the green one we used that day?
Lucia:就是这也行啊
Lucia: This one works too.
其他人:他就看库存就能看出来
Others: He can tell by checking the inventory.
其他人:这个东西他觉得真不真哦
Others: He can tell if it's real or not.
其他人:哎这还都响
Others: Oh, this is all ringing.
Lucia:不过反正也吃上了哈哈
Lucia: But anyway, we got to eat it, haha.
其他人:我靠这摆盘有点怎么怎么
Other: Wow, this plating is kinda...
其他人:又低了一下头就已经摆完了
Other: I just looked down and it's already done.
其他人:我操你吃完了
Other: Damn, you finished eating already?
其他人:放上去放上去
Other: Put it up, put it up.
Lucia:啊那行
Lucia: Ah, okay.
其他人：卧槽太屌了
Other: Wow, that's awesome.
Tasha:为什么要把他们强行塞在一起
Tasha: Why are you forcing them together?
Jake:方便拍照
Jake: For easier photo taking.
Jake:咱还有道具呢
Jake: We also have props.
Jake:在后面再摆一个显得很多
Jake: Put another one in the back to make it look like there's more.
Alice:你你能不能把这个汇源果汁挡一下
Alice: Can you block this Huiyuan juice?
Jake:我们有整整两大盆
Jake: We have two big bowls of it.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Jake:现在还有什
Jake: Now what else...
Jake:还有什么
Jake: What else do we have?
Jake:提拉米苏
Jake: Tiramisu.
Lucia:但是就是因为这是木头的
Lucia: But because this is made of wood,
Lucia:所以他就是上面的有可能会有刺
Lucia: the top might have some splinters.
Lucia:会把这个稍微刮下来
Lucia: It might scratch off a bit.
Lucia:呃那个好像不能直接用
Lucia: Uh, that one might not be usable directly.
Lucia:或者能直接洗一下可能也行
Lucia: Or you could just wash it directly, maybe that's fine.
Jake:那我过水了
Jake: I'll rinse it then.
Tasha:完了这个盆放不下
Tasha: Oh no, this bowl is too small.
Tasha:有没有放个大点的盆给我
Tasha: Do you have a bigger bowl for me?
Lucia:这个有没有更大一点
Lucia: Do you have a bigger one?
Lucia:或者
Lucia: Or...
Alice:这个吧
Alice: How about this one?
Alice:这个或者这个这个吧
Alice: This one or this one?
Jake:戴眼镜吧
Jake: Wear glasses.
Alice:手指饼干呢
Alice: Where are the ladyfingers?
Lucia:这要擦一下吗
Lucia: Should we wipe this?
Lucia:拿出来了
Lucia: Got the ladyfingers.
Lucia:手指饼干
Lucia: Ladyfingers.
Tasha:不用了不用了哦
Tasha: No need, no need.
Alice:哦
Alice: Oh.
Lucia:小心小心
Lucia: Careful, careful.
其他人:一下蘸
Other: Just dip it.
Alice:不是蘸一下咖啡
Alice: Aren't we dipping it in coffee?
其他人:一下咖啡蘸一下那个蘸一下咖啡
Other: Just dip it in coffee, dip it in coffee.
Alice:蘸一下那个
Alice: Dip it.
Alice:没事等一会吧
Alice: It's okay, just wait a bit.
其他人:然后我
Others: And then I...
Alice:烤啊不烤就直接放那
Alice: Roast it or just leave it there.
Alice:蘸一下然后放在那个夹层里
Alice: Dip it and then put it in the middle layer.
Shure: 外面是不是有点小冷
Shure: Is it a bit cold outside?
Shure: 谁开的 16度
Shure: Who set it to 16 degrees?
Shure: 你在家不挨揍吗
Shure: Don't you get scolded at home?
Jake:这就是京爷
Jake: That's just how King is.
其他人：今天要热死了
Others: It's going to be so hot today.
Jake:京爷
Jake: King.
Alice:你是突然出现的吗
Alice: Did you just appear out of nowhere?
Alice:刚刚你在这吗
Alice: Were you just here?
Shure: 我刚刚不在这
Shure: I wasn't just here.
Shure: 我刚刚开会去了
Shure: I just came back from a meeting.
Shure: 牛排呢吃没了都
Shure: Where's the steak? Is it all gone?
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Shure: 牛排吃没了
Shure: The steak is all gone.
Jake:我怎么调啊
Jake: How do I adjust it?
Jake:我靠为什么哦
Jake: Why, oh why?
Alice:给
Alice: Here.
Jake:26了都行
Jake: 26 degrees is fine.
其他人：这是什么
Others: What is this?
Alice:这呢
Alice: Here.
Shure: 卧槽
Shure: Whoa.
Tasha:这个咖啡
Tasha: This coffee.
Alice:这个这个咖啡咖啡液奥
Alice: This, this coffee, coffee liquid.
其他人：提拉米苏是吧
Others: Is this tiramisu?
Alice:对
Alice: Yes.
Tasha:滚两圈
Tasha: Roll it twice.
Tasha:对
Tasha: Right.
Tasha: 手指饼干
Tasha: Ladyfingers.
Jake:哦想吃了已经
Jake: Oh, I want to eat it already.
Tasha:哇好高级
Tasha: Wow, so fancy.
Tasha:哎你这样放太多了
Tasha: Hey, you put too much.
Alice:太快了
Alice: Too fast.
Tasha:这饼干全部都不能要了
Tasha: These cookies are all ruined.
Alice:哎呀不行了
Alice: Oh no, it's not working.
其他人:没事没事我这还有几个
Others: It's okay, it's okay, I have a few more here.
Tasha:呃这几个都不能要了哦
Tasha: Uh, these few are all ruined too.
Katrina: 哎
Katrina: Hey.
其他人：哦它已经软了是吧
Others: Oh, it's already soft, right?
Alice:对对我来吧
Alice: Yes, yes, I'll do it.
Lucia:拿个勺把它舀出来
Lucia: Use a spoon to scoop it out.
其他人：对拿个筷子
Others: Yes, use chopsticks.
Tasha:这几个把咖啡液全部都吸走了
Tasha: These few pieces absorbed all the coffee liquid.
Shure: 哎呀哎呀哎呀
Shure: Oh no, oh no, oh no.
Shure: 其他人：
Shure: Others:
其他人：问题不是很大
Others: It's not a big problem.
Jake:没事你先吃了吧要不
Jake: It's okay, just eat it first.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
其他人：而且那还有一双
Others: And there's another pair.
Tasha:继续搁吧
Tasha: Continue putting it.
其他人：而且咖啡液也还有
Others: And there's more coffee liquid.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Got it.
Lucia:那几个要不要弄一下
Lucia: Do we need to handle those few?
Shure: 我想吃个咸鸭蛋
Shure: I want to eat a salted duck egg.
Lucia:还是放那就行那行
Lucia: Just leave them there, it's fine.
Jake:咸鸭蛋
Jake: Salted duck egg?
Shure: 吃过吧杨老板
Shure: Have you had it, Jake?
Jake:吃还是常吃
Jake: Yes, I often eat it.
其他人：要不再弄个咖啡
Others: Should we make another coffee?
Alice:没事
Alice: It's fine.
Tasha:要重新弄可能
Tasha: We might need to redo it.
其他人:没事没事还有那个
Others: It's okay, there's still that.
其他人:算了不行我还给你手穿了
Others: Forget it, I can't, I'll help you instead.
Shure: 不行我还可以手冲
Shure: No, I can still do it myself.
Tasha:搁
Tasha: Okay.
其他人:然后再来一盘就能吃了
Others: Then make another plate and it's ready to eat.
Tasha:对
Tasha: Yes.
Tasha:还要再来一盘
Tasha: Still need to make another plate.
Tasha:就就这些
Tasha: That's all.
其他人:没有没有
Others: No, no.
其他人:那还有一包
Others: There's still another pack.
Lucia:这个可以先放回去
Lucia: This can be put back first.
Lucia:要把它舀出来用着吃
Lucia: Scoop it out and eat it.
Alice:没事
Alice: It's fine.
其他人：你要单吃一个
Others: Are you going to eat one alone?
其他人:这上面不是撒了一层糖吗
Others: There's a layer of sugar on top.
其他人:为什么这个有菠萝味啊
Others: Why does this one taste like pineapple?
Alice:里面放菠萝了
Alice: There's pineapple inside.
Lucia:有菠萝夹心
Lucia: There's pineapple filling.
其他人:我放菠萝
Others: I added pineapple.
Alice:夹带了
Alice: It's mixed in.
Alice:呵呵呵
Alice: Hehehe.
Shure: OK OK
Shure: OK OK.
Jake:夹带了哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: It's mixed in hahaha.
Lucia:哈哈哈要是没有了上面没有
Lucia: Haha, if there's none on top...
Tasha:上面上面有没有的
Tasha: Is there any on top?
Shure: 可以发视频审核
Shure: We can send the video for review.
Tasha:上面没有
Tasha: There's none on top.
Lucia:要是没有就更
Lucia: If there's none, then...
Jake:我也整一个
Jake: I'll make one too.
Shure: 你失败了
Shure: You failed.
Tasha:你失败了
Tasha: You failed.
Tasha:刘帅受到了大家的批评
Tasha: Choiszt received criticism from everyone.
其他人：就一个人批评
Others: Just one person criticized.
Jake:对我这个
Jake: Right, mine...
Jake:来表扬一下
Jake: Let's praise it.
Jake:这有没有菠萝
Jake: Does this have pineapple?
Jake:不一定没有
Jake: It might not have any.
Jake:这这有菠萝吗
Jake: Does this have pineapple?
Alice:这个没有
Alice: This one doesn't.
Tasha:没有了你看你要是不拿走刚刚好
Tasha: If it doesn't, you see, if you don't take it...
其他人：把这个挤一下
Others: Squeeze this one.
其他人:就是拿手上捏
Others: Just squeeze it with your hands.
Alice:谁来捏
Alice: Who wants to squeeze?
Lucia:不知道
Lucia: Don't know.
其他人:也可以来几个
Others: We can do a few.
其他人:没有提拉米苏味的或者其他味的
Others: Without tiramisu flavor or other flavors.
其他人:抹茶味的
Others: Matcha flavor.
Tasha:怎么样都是需要手指饼干的
Tasha: Anyway, you need ladyfingers.
其他人:或者可乐味
Others: Or cola flavor.
Shure: 这是咸鸭蛋
Shure: This is salted duck egg.
Shure: 有点咸但是哈哈哈哈
Shure: A bit salty but hahaha.
Shure: 真香这话听说过
Shure: It smells good, have you heard that before?
Jake:你听说过高油咸鸭蛋吗
Jake: Have you heard of high-oil salted duck eggs?
Shure: 听说过
Shure: Heard of it.
其他人:小说嘛嗯
Others: It's in novels, huh?
其他人:非常的真的吗
Others: Very real, right?
Shure: 真的吗
Shure: Really?
其他人:好吃嗯
Others: Tastes good, hmm.
Shure: 真的是王胜奇的小说吗
Shure: Is it really Wang Shengqi's novel?
其他人:好像是个高油鸭蛋
Others: Seems like a high-fat duck egg.
Shure: 我是个仗玉我不知道
Shure: I’m just a warrior of jade, I don’t know.
其他人:我也不知道
Others: I don’t know either.
其他人:我只是撕
Others: I’m just tearing it.
其他人:要捏一个嘛
Others: Do you need to knead it?
Lucia:哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Tasha:不知道该怎么办
Tasha: I don’t know what to do.
其他人：没事少一个也无所谓
Others: It’s okay, one less won’t matter.
Alice:你把这个搁这这底下这个
Alice: Put this here, underneath this.
其他人：这么多人都吃不了
Others: So many people can’t finish it.
Shure: 哎呀妈
Shure: Oh my mom.
其他人:好吃的吃这个你也吃
Others: It’s good, eat this, you eat too.
Shure: 牛排怎么这么受欢迎呢
Shure: Why is steak so popular?
Jake:是直接吃吗
Jake: Do we eat it directly?
Jake:啊饱了和和和会吧
Jake: Ah, full and satisfied, right?
Shure: 我出来都没了
Shure: I came out and it’s all gone.
其他人：哦你没吃
Others: Oh, you didn’t eat.
Jake:休息一下休息一下
Jake: Take a break, take a break.
Shure: 我吃了个饺子
Shure: I ate a dumpling.
其他人:这奶油吗
Others: Is this cream?
Alice:这是
Alice: This is.
其他人:是这是什么东西
Others: What is this?
Jake:提拉米苏啊
Jake: Tiramisu.
Alice:嗯这个
Alice: Hmm, this one.
其他人:提拉米苏
Others: Tiramisu.
Tasha:这个先不加
Tasha: Don’t add this yet.
其他人：我印象中的提拉米苏怎么是方方正正的
Others: The tiramisu I remember is square.
Jake:他可能烤完之后就是方方正正的
Jake: Maybe it’s square after baking.
Tasha:还没切呢
Tasha: It’s not cut yet.
Shure: 在哪拿的打火机
Shure: Where did you get the lighter?
Tasha::有没有可能等会切一下就是了
Tasha: Maybe after cutting it, it will be.
Jake:他烤完之后他就变成了一层又一层
Jake: After baking, it turns into layers.
Shure: 好差点就卸了
Shure: Almost took it apart.
Tasha:拇指饼干没了
Tasha: The ladyfinger biscuits are gone.
Katrina: 我这我这回去又边P又这个
Katrina: When I go back, I’ll be editing and doing this.
Alice:没就一包
Alice: No, just one pack.
Shure: 呵呵呵呵
Shure: Hehehehe.
Tasha:再来再来再来调一层
Tasha: Add another layer, add another layer.
其他人：我发现一个问题
Other: I noticed a problem.
其他人：就是他已经拿了我打火机打了两天啊
Other: He's been using my lighter for two days now.
其他人：哈哈哈哈
Other: Hahaha.
Shure: 哦
Shure: Oh.
其他人:我得亏我得亏
Other: I'm so lucky.
其他人:抖音买了个打火机
Other: I bought a lighter on TikTok.
Katrina: 我的教程呢
Katrina: Where's my tutorial?
Shure: why are this new
Shure: Why are this new?
Shure: （歌词）梦里梦到醒不来的梦黑暗里被软禁的
Shure: (Lyrics) Dreaming of a dream I can't wake up from, imprisoned in the dark.
Lucia:哎呦哇没崩到水吧
Lucia: Oh no, did it spill on the water?
Tasha:没事没事没事
Tasha: It's okay, it's okay, it's okay.
Tasha:还差200克热水
Tasha: Still need 200 grams of hot water.
Tasha:再烧200克
Tasha: Boil another 200 grams.
Jake:师傅没开机啊
Jake: The master didn't turn it on.
Jake:大师啊
Jake: Master!
Jake:眼睛怎么再再整一下
Jake: What's wrong with your eyes?
Jake:再给人再给人整一下
Jake: Fix them again.
Tasha:糖
Tasha: Sugar.
Tasha:烧20克就行了
Tasha: Just boil 20 grams.
Alice:200
Alice: 200.
Tasha:你加的越多烧的越慢
Tasha: The more you add, the slower it boils.
Lucia:少倒倒掉点
Lucia: Pour out some.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
其他人:那其实如果你这个都泡了以后泡的话
Other: Actually, if you soak this after everything...
其他人:就刚才那点那几个饼干也应该加进去
Other: You should've added those biscuits too.
其他人:就也可以加进去先烤开了
Other: You can add them first and bake them.
Alice:你抄底的时候可能拖不住要点
Alice: When you bottom out, you might need a bit.
其他人:但是你现在加完了以后
Other: But after adding it now...
其他人:他底下不也没泡了
Other: It's not soaking the bottom.
Shure: 我的可乐呢
Shure: Where's my Coke?
其他人:就你现在加完这个
Other: After adding this...
其他人:这不也稀的吗
Other: Isn't it still thin?
其他人:那你底下那种那边有个空盒
Other: There's an empty box over there.
Jake:那没人喝的可乐你喝没事还会冷藏
Jake: If nobody's drinking that Coke, you can have it. It'll still be cold.
Alice:啊没事还会冷藏
Alice: Oh, it's okay, it'll still be cold.
Shure: 啊OK
Shure: Ah, okay.
Jake:这里头
Jake: Inside here.
Shure: 哎卧槽
Shure: Oh crap.
Shure: 我的尾巴夹住了
Shure: My tail got stuck.
Tasha:谁摔了没事
Tasha: Who fell? It's okay.
Shure: 你的你的眼镜没电了啊
Shure: Your glasses are out of battery.
Katrina: 刚刚还有电
Katrina: They had power just now.
Katrina: 刚刚在楼上的时候照镜子
Katrina: I was looking in the mirror upstairs just now.
Lucia:不行
Lucia: No way.
Shure: 呵可能是
Shure: Haha, maybe...
Shure: 呵你你的脸突然把他抱内存了
Shure: Haha, your face suddenly overloaded its memory.
Shure: 呵呵呵
Shure: Hahaha.
Jake:插根插插电吧
Jake: Plug it in.
Jake:应该还是有
Jake: It should still have some power.
Tasha:还没有连上吧
Tasha: It's not connected yet, right?
Shure: 我们是不是没有排练歌曲啊家人们
Shure: Didn't we practice the song, guys?
Alice:是这样的
Alice: That's right.
Alice:QA也没有准备吧
Alice: And we didn't prepare the Q&A either, right?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Jake:要不就
Jake: How about we...
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure: 哦q a也没做呢
Shure: Oh, we didn't do the Q&A either.
Jake:做一个呗
Jake: Let's do one.
Alice:还有藏币
Alice: And we have the hidden coins.
Jake:藏币现藏币
Jake: Hidden coins, everyone.
Jake:大家大大伙
Jake: Everyone, let's hide the coins first.
Jake:大伙先藏币吧
Jake: Let's hide the coins first.
Alice:币呢
Alice: Where are the coins?
Jake:币在这这
Jake: The coins are right here.
Alice:这是币吗
Alice: Are these the coins?
Lucia:实际上我屋甚至还没整理
Lucia: Actually, I haven't even tidied my room yet.
Jake:不是不是
Jake: No, no.
Shure: 我们b呢
Shure: Where are our coins?
Alice:还没装修呢哈哈
Alice: We haven't even renovated, haha.
Lucia:对
Lucia: Right.
Lucia:每天都有好多事
Lucia: There's so much to do every day.
Katrina: 我也变批了
Katrina: I've also become a mess.
Jake:那工人怎么
Jake: So what about the workers?
Jake:咱怎么办
Jake: What should we do?
Jake:工人已经救不了了是吧
Jake: The workers can't be saved, right?
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Shure: 勾人勾人已经变批了
Shure: The workers have also become a mess.
Jake:一直是失一直是失控的状态哈哈
Jake: It's always been out of control, haha.
Jake:我操
Jake: Damn.
Lucia:那要不摆烂吧
Lucia: Then how about we just give up?
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha
Shure: 快勾人快快勾人
Shure: Hurry up and hook someone, hurry, hurry
Shure: 勾人快快
Shure: Hook someone, hurry, hurry
Shure: 你不急吗勾
Shure: Aren't you in a hurry, hook them
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Shure: 我好急
Shure: I'm in such a hurry
其他人：是非常勾吗牛逼
Others: Is it really hooking? Awesome
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈你回头
Jake: Hahahahaha, look back
Shure: 你以前是飞
Shure: You used to be a flyer
Jake:你回头再测一下
Jake: Look back and test it again
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Haha
Jake:你今天晚上当着我坐着别测一下
Jake: Sit with me tonight, don't test it
其他人：你今天晚上当着测试别测一下啊
Others: Sit with us tonight, don't test it
Shure: 我们今天
Shure: Today we
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Haha
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on
Shure: 把那个投投个屏开始给你测一下
Shure: Cast the screen and start testing it
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahahaha
其他人：哈哈哈投个屏牛逼
Others: Hahaha, cast the screen, awesome
Shure: 公开处刑
Shure: Public execution
Lucia:这玩意能放哪啊
Lucia: Where can we put this thing?
Jake:我试试是不是这个没开啊
Jake: Let me see if this is not turned on
Jake:哦他这个没开
Jake: Oh, it's not turned on
Lucia:啊
Lucia: Ah
Jake:确实没开
Jake: It's really not turned on
Jake:然后这个肯定是没插
Jake: And this one is definitely not plugged in
Lucia:够够够够够
Lucia: Enough, enough, enough
Jake:这个是要不就插好了
Jake: This one is either plugged in or not
其他人:插好了
Others: It's plugged in
Jake:有电不是
Jake: There's power, right?
Jake:有电但是没开
Jake: There's power but it's not on
Shure: 你要找b
Shure: You need to find B
Jake:开了就就
Jake: Once it's on, then...
Katrina: 不是我现在找b
Katrina: No, now I'm looking for B
Jake:他显然没充电啊
Jake: It's obviously not charged
Jake:我靠这100%开玩笑的啊
Jake: Wow, this is 100%, just kidding
Jake:呵呵就是就是
Jake: Haha, that's it
Katrina: 我想要做我的风铃
Katrina: I want to make my wind chime
Jake:他没开他有电但是没开
Jake: It's not on, it has power but it's not on
Shure: 你先把币找着行不行
Shure: Can you find the coins first?
Jake:哎这其他人:
Jake: Hey, everyone:
Jake:这咋不开啊
Jake: Why won't this open?
其他人:那没电了呀
Others: It's out of power.
Alice:嗯那个热水可以递给我一下吗
Alice: Um, can you pass me the hot water?
Jake:对要开机了
Jake: Yeah, it needs to be turned on.
Jake:他得一直闪着他才有电
Jake: It has to keep flashing to have power.
Shure: 你在这充不就好了吗
Shure: Why don't you just charge it here?
其他人:所以他机了是吧
Others: So it's on, right?
Jake:他机了不是不是不是你插
Jake: It's on, no, no, no, you plug it in.
Alice:啊谢谢
Alice: Ah, thanks.
Tasha:200克就行
Tasha: 200 grams is enough.
Alice:哎呦
Alice: Ouch.
Jake:了呀你
Jake: Yeah, you.
Shure: 你把那插排插上不就得了吗
Shure: Just plug in the power strip, that'll do.
Alice:嗯好
Alice: Okay, got it.
Jake:他要有电
Jake: It needs power.
其他人:充电宝充电宝有电OK
Others: The power bank, the power bank has power, OK.
Jake:但是你开着的时候他在充电
Jake: But when you turn it on, it's charging.
Shure: 哎你不用你先找币
Shure: Hey, you don't need it, find the coins first.
Shure: 你的计划没有用
Shure: Your plan is useless.
Shure: 你把币给我找着
Shure: Just find me the coins.
Shure: 你快把币给我
Shure: Hurry up and give me the coins.
Shure: 不然我就给你锁外边
Shure: Or I'll lock you outside.
Katrina: 天哪这么乱
Katrina: Oh my, such a mess.
Katrina: 我那个快递你帮我拿那个呢
Katrina: Can you help me with my package?
Shure: 你问问杨老板
Shure: Ask Jake.
Shure: 那个大的粗的是吗
Shure: The big thick one, right?
Shure: 杨老板拿着
Shure: Jake's holding it.
Katrina: 嗯
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Yeah.
Katrina: 唉怎么看他有没有在充电
Katrina: Hey, how do I know if it's charging?
Shure: 它亮他就充着了
Shure: If it's lit up, it's charging.
Shure: 你都没插你你充
Shure: You didn't plug it in, how are you charging?
Shure: 妈呀呵呵呵
Shure: Oh my gosh, hahaha.
Shure: OK好
Shure: OK, good.
Shure: 现在充上了
Shure: Now it's charging.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Yeah.
Lucia:这还有两根哎
Lucia: There are two more here.
Tasha:这俩别浪费
Tasha: Don't waste these two.
Alice:直接用手吧
Alice: Just use your hands.
Alice:你那个你那个有底
Alice: You know, you know it's got a bottom.
Alice:我放
Alice: I'll put it.
Lucia:提拉米苏
Lucia: Tiramisu.
其他人:为什么为什么这样
Others: Why, why like this?
Tasha:哎你别搞这么快
Tasha: Hey, don't go so fast.
其他人:为什么你这样子搞这么快啊
Others: Why are you doing it so fast?
Shure: 你怎么屡教不改呢
Shure: Why don't you ever learn?
Lucia:为什么要提拉米苏
Lucia: Why tiramisu?
Jake:刘帅哈哈怎么还在放呢
Jake: Choiszt, haha, why are you still putting it?
Shure: 刘帅
Shure: Choiszt.
Lucia:就是做底
Lucia: It's the base.
Lucia:就是这个手指饼干
Lucia: It's the ladyfingers.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia:这提拉米苏里面
Lucia: In this tiramisu.
其他人:等会再放等会再放
Others: Wait a bit, wait a bit.
Shure: 还在放
Shure: Still putting it.
Jake:你等会再放你等会再放等会再放啊
Jake: Wait a bit, wait a bit, wait a bit.
Lucia:他本本来
Lucia: He originally...
Jake:哎呀完了
Jake: Oh no, it's ruined.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
其他人：哎完了他他一会他一会要跳起来抽你
Others: Oh no, he's gonna jump up and hit you later.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Oh.
其他人:因为我感觉他真的已经非常重要
Others: Because I feel like he's really important.
Jake:行行行开除开除开除
Jake: Alright, alright, you're fired, you're fired.
Shure: 就是
Shure: Exactly.
Jake:好换一个换一个你
Jake: Okay, switch, switch you.
其他人:你等他
Others: Wait for him.
其他人:你等他摆完你再放你等他摆完你再放
Others: Wait for him to finish before you put it, wait for him to finish.
其他人:我知道我知道
Others: I know, I know.
Shure: 他就是属于
Shure: He's just like...
Jake:你知道个球
Jake: You know nothing.
Jake:你知道哈哈哈
Jake: You know, hahaha.
Shure: 哈哈哈好好的
Shure: Hahaha, alright.
Shure: 我错了但是我下次继续
Shure: I was wrong, but I'll do it again next time.
其他人:心里有数心里有数心里有数
Others: We get it, we get it, we get it.
Jake:有哈哈
Jake: Yeah, haha.
其他人:哈哈哈来
Others: Hahaha, come on.
其他人:那怎么就多一层啊
Others: Why is there an extra layer?
Alice:没事无妨
Alice: It's okay, no problem.
Jake:哈哈哈多吃一口多好
Jake: Hahaha, eating another bite is great.
Jake:这是尖锐你知道吧哈哈哈
Jake: This is sharp, you know? Hahaha.
Shure: 你快骂我
Shure: Hurry up and scold me.
Shure: （歌词） 天的黑不是黑
Shure: (Lyrics) The darkness of the night isn't really dark.
Shure: （歌词） 你说的白是什么白
Shure: (Lyrics) What kind of white are you talking about?
其他人:这这一层是平这波
Others: This layer is balanced in this wave.
其他人:这波无法
Others: This wave is impossible.
Alice:无妨开
Alice: No worries, go ahead.
其他人:开但是有点浪费
Others: Go ahead, but it's a bit wasteful.
Alice:没事你剩下你可以吃边边角角
Alice: It's okay, you can eat the edges.
Tasha:然后现场就吃掉
Tasha: Then just eat it on the spot.
Tasha:现场就吃
Tasha: Eat it on the spot.
其他人:哎这其实也可以塞下是吧
Others: Hey, this could actually fit, right?
其他人:就其他的啊
Others: Just the other stuff.
Tasha:嗯现场就吃
Tasha: Yeah, eat it on the spot.
Tasha:你准备几个小托盘
Tasha: Prepare a few small trays.
Tasha:咱们现场吃掉它好吃吗
Tasha: We'll eat it on the spot, is it tasty?
其他人:好吃吗
Others: Is it tasty?
其他人:所以这个蛋挞是我们自己开的酥吗
其他人:还是买好的酥皮吗
Others: Or did we buy the crust?
其他人:买好的那个皮
Others: Bought the crust.
其他人:哦
Others: Oh.
Jake:我们来币了
Jake:我们来币
Jake:哦哦可能在这里边
Jake: Oh, maybe it's in here.
Lucia:哎我今天早上还看见它了
Lucia: Hey, I saw him this morning.
Jake:币在哪啊
Jake:你知道吗
Jake: Do you know?
Tasha:吃吧吃吧
Tasha: Eat, eat.
Lucia:在那吗不在
Lucia: There? No.
Shure: 雨轩在找雨轩在找币
Shure: Yuxuan is looking for the coins.
Tasha:这个哎
Tasha: This, hey.
Tasha:好吧最后一个还剩几个
Tasha: Alright, how many are left?
Tasha:我们吃掉
Tasha: Let's eat them.
其他人:还有6 还有8个啊
Others: There are 6, no 8 left.
其他人:6个哎这还有7个
Others: 6, oh, there are 7.
Shure: 这世界总有人在忙忙碌碌寻宝藏
Shure: There are always people in this world busy searching for treasures.
Shure: 你快找币
Shure: Hurry up and find the coins.
Shure: 没有
Shure: No.
Shure: 我还很正常
Shure: I'm still normal.
Katrina: 找到了
Katrina: Found it.
Jake:哪个桌子上
Jake: Which table?
Shure: 找到了
Shure: Spare me.
Jake:这个桌子上
Jake: On this table.
Shure: 来吧这是什么币
Shure: Come on, what kind of coin is this?
Shure: 就是贴纸是吗
Shure: It's just a sticker, right?
Katrina: 特别好看看这
Katrina: It's really nice. Look at this.
Katrina: 这什么这这
Katrina: What's this... this...
Katrina: 不是看这
Katrina: No, look at this.
Katrina: 只要看这影就行好
Katrina: Just look at the shadow, okay?
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Katrina: 明天我同学来之前我一定会把书
Katrina: Before my classmate comes tomorrow, I'll definitely...
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Katrina: 相信我
Katrina: Trust me.
Shure: 我相信你
Shure: I trust you.
Shure: 不相信我
Shure: I don't trust myself.
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Jake:藏找到了
Jake: The stash was found.
Shure: 找到了找到币了
Shure: Found it, found the coin.
Jake:藏挺好藏
Jake: The stash was well hidden.
Jake:藏哪了
Jake: Where was it hidden?
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia:哎上面的桌子上
Lucia: On the table above.
Shure: 就是贴纸贴
Shure: It's just a sticker.
其他人：哦高级
Others: Oh, fancy.
Shure: 纸
Shure: Paper.
Lucia:啊
Lucia: Ah.
Shure: 藏到你的
Shure: Hide it in your...
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Lucia:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahahahahaha.
其他人:是不是这个
Others: Is it this one?
其他人:就是这个
Others: It's this one.
其他人: 不是就是这个
Others: No, it's this one.
Shure: 不是这个不是这个
Shure: It's not this one, not this one.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahaha.
Jake:什么意思啊
Jake: What does it mean?
Lucia:猛男脱衣舞
Lucia: Male stripper.
Katrina: 这也能当币吧
Katrina: This can be used as a coin, right?
Jake:啊可以可
Jake: Ah, it's okay.
Shure: 可以但是我们就有假币
Shure: It's okay, but we have counterfeit money.
Jake:以当币这个算
Jake: Let's count it as currency.
Shure: 这是良币隐藏款
Shure: This is the hidden good money.
Katrina: 隐藏款
Katrina: Hidden money.
Jake:这这这算一分的吧
Jake: Does this count as one point?
Jake:这类似于一块的
Jake: This is like one piece.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahahahahaha
Shure: 你滚
Shure: Get out.
其他人：警惕劣币
Lucia:劣币驱逐良币
Lucia: Bad money drives out good money.
Shure: 这是良币
Shure: This is good money.
Katrina: 那就是每个人大约有几个人
Katrina: So, how many people are there approximately?
Alice:这只有16多了
Alice: There are only 16, that's too many.
Shure: 这有150个吗
Shure: Are there 150 of these?
Jake:16的
Jake: 16 of them.
Lucia:有吧一包50个啊行
Lucia: Yeah, there's a pack of 50, right?
Jake:1616 够16
Jake: 16, 16, that's enough.
Jake:够16 再干20分钟
Jake: 16 is enough, let's work for another 20 minutes.
Katrina: 我们每人藏自己的
Katrina: Everyone hide their own.
Katrina: 房间
Katrina: In their rooms.
Shure: 不是要藏在厅里面吗
Shure: Aren't we supposed to hide it in the living room?
Shure: 房间不是
Shure: Not in the rooms?
Jake:对会存会存
Jake: Yes, we will store it.
Katrina: 那是要带他们参观房间吗
Katrina: Are we supposed to show them around the rooms?
Katrina: 你也见不得人
Katrina: You can't be seen.
Katrina: ：你别笑话我你喂
Katrina: Don't make fun of me, hey.
Shure: 你
Shure: You...
Jake:不用藏房间
Jake: No need to hide in rooms.
Lucia:主要是藏房间的话藏外面就行了啊
Lucia: Mainly, if we hide it in rooms, we can just hide it outside.
Jake:不藏房间
Jake: Not hiding in rooms.
Lucia:那就好
Lucia: That's good.
Jake:就在外边
Jake: Just outside.
Lucia:要不然行李没地放
Lucia: Otherwise, there's no place for luggage.
Alice:藏那上面呗
Alice: Just hide it up there.
Jake:不能让他们爬
Jake: We can't let them climb.
Lucia:不能让他
Lucia: Can't let them...
Lucia:难度是不是有点太高了
Lucia: Is it too difficult?
Jake:不能让他们碰到相机
Jake: We can't let them touch the camera.
Jake:燕子可以不能爬相机
Jake: The camera can be moved, but they can't climb to the camera.
Alice:能藏这里面
Alice: It can be hidden in here.
Jake:我去哈哈哈
Jake: Oh my gosh, haha.
Alice:哎这怎么连个拉锁都没有
Alice: Hey, why doesn't this even have a zipper?
Shure: 他连屁股都没有
Shure: It doesn't even have a bottom.
Shure: 我们还没藏呢
Shure: We haven't hidden it yet.
Jake:你就我们找到了找
Jake: You just find it, find it.
Shure: 你找找你再找
Shure: You keep looking.
Jake:藏这了藏这了就
Jake: Hide it here, just hide it here.
Shure: 这有50吗
Shure: Is there 50 here?
其他人：这有50吗
Shure: 5050
Shure: 50, 50.
其他人：150坏了150
Others: 150, it’s broken, 150.
Jake:150 我们匀个50来藏还是多少来着
Jake: 150, should we split 50 to hide or how much was it?
Shure: 多少用来藏你
Shure: How much to use for hiding you?
Jake:藏个20吧
Jake: Hide 20.
Shure: 20
Shure: 20.
其他人：很难藏啊就这么大
Others: It's hard to hide, it's this big.
Jake:藏20吧能藏在每个人的房间吗
Jake: Hide 20, can we hide it in everyone's rooms?
Shure: 对啊
Shure: Yeah.
其他人：能藏在每个人的房间藏这吗
Others: Can we hide it in everyone's rooms, hide it here?
Jake:不能不能就20吧
Jake: No, no, just 20.
Alice:藏这吗
Alice: Hide it here?
Shure: 不能
Shure: No.
Alice:就这底下
Alice: Underneath here.
Jake:藏他20
Jake: Hide his 20.
Katrina: 再让嘉宾往下爬
Katrina: Let the guest crawl down again.
Alice:他不一定
Alice: He might not.
Alice:他不一定会爬呀
Alice: He might not even crawl.
Jake:藏他20个哈
Jake: Hide his 20, huh.
Shure: eco friendly
Shure: Eco friendly.
其他人:是不是ECO friend
Others: Is it ECO friend?
其他人:我以为是environmental friend
Others: I thought it was environmental friend.
Shure: 不知道
Shure: I don't know.
Jake:呃是都可以都可以都可以
Jake: Uh, it could be either, either, either.
Shure: 可能他要要打把eco局吧
Shure: Maybe he wants to play an eco game.
Jake:能冲进去
Jake: Can rush in.
Alice:这每个都长不一样吗
Alice: Are all of these different?
Alice:是多少组啊
Alice: How many groups are there?
Tasha:干嘛
Tasha: What's up?
Jake:拿我的哼
Jake: Take mine, hmm.
Shure: 想到明天就能见到你
Shure: Thinking about seeing you tomorrow...
Shure: 就是这个抑制不住的兴奋与激动
Shure: I'm just so excited and thrilled.
Lucia:感觉我藏完明天就忘了自己藏哪了
Lucia: I feel like I'll forget where I hid it by tomorrow.
Katrina: 啊不要拿
Katrina: Ah, don't take it.
Katrina: 我这已经20个了
Katrina: I already have 20 here.
Katrina: ：我们要控制一下控制
Katrina: We need to control ourselves.
Shure: 控制
Jake:你试试
Jake: Give it a try.
Katrina: 发挥你的想象力
Katrina: Use your imagination.
Shure: 好我的想象力
Shure: Alright, my imagination.
Shure: 哎sorry sorry
Shure: Oh, sorry, sorry.
Jake:可以可以可以
Jake: It's okay, it's okay.
Lucia:你放在哪里了
Lucia: Where did you put it?
Lucia:哦哎很棒
Lucia: Oh wow, that's great.
Jake:大对大伙藏
Jake: Everyone hides together.
Shure: 可以吧
Shure: Is that okay?
Jake:然后给我们
Jake: Then give it to us.
Jake:就我们内部先知道一下
Jake: We'll know about it first internally.
Jake:好吧内部明天就忘了
Jake: Alright, we'll forget it by tomorrow.
Lucia:好吧估计内部明天就忘了
Lucia: Yeah, we'll probably forget it by tomorrow.
Shure: 这里
Shure: Here.
Jake:对对对不然自己都不记得了
Jake: Right, otherwise we'll forget ourselves.
Shure: 我们这可都是项链的
Shure: We're all wearing necklaces.
Lucia:海盗船长忘记了宝藏牌在哪里
Lucia: The pirate captain forgot where he put the treasure map.
Shure: one piece
Shure: One Piece.
Lucia:全剧终
Lucia: The end.
Jake:呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe.
Shure: 看我藏那了
Shure: Look where I hid it.
Shure: 是不是不易被发现
Shure: Hard to find, right?
Alice:哎等一下
Alice: Hey, wait a second.
Jake:哪哪啊你藏哪了
Jake: Where, where did you hide it?
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure: 牛吧
Shure: Impressive, right?
Jake:牛
Jake: Impressive.
Lucia:哦
Lucia: Oh.
Jake:挺好
Jake: Nice.
Alice:你别动
Alice: Don't move.
Shure: 咋了
Shure: What's up?
Jake:那给我一个
Jake: Give me one.
Jake:我也要藏
Jake: I want to hide too.
Alice:我也要这能藏藏
Alice: I want to hide it too.
Jake:藏人头上是吧
Jake: Hide it on top of someone's head, right?
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on.
Jake:我觉得可以藏
Jake: I think it can be hidden.
Shure: 哎呦不行
Shure: Oh no, that's not gonna work.
Jake:藏头里藏里
Jake: Hide it in the hair.
Jake:发卡里哈哈哈
Jake: In the hair clip, hahaha.
Alice:藏
Alice: Hide it.
Shure: 我这头发能能藏
Shure: My hair can hide it.
Shure: 藏20个是吧
Shure: Hide 20 of them, right?
Lucia:放书架上了
Lucia: Put it on the shelf.
Shure: 谁给老子发消息了
Shure: Who's sending me messages?
Alice:哎呀找一个瘦一点的
Alice: Ah, find one that's thinner.
Shure: 你看我那就很不明显
Shure: Look, it's not obvious on me.
Alice:哎呀没有掉
Alice: Ah, it didn't fall.
其他人:很明显了
Others: It's very obvious.
Shure: 哎我操
Shure: Oh crap.
其他人:我藏了一个
Others: I hid one.
Jake:你藏哪去了
Jake: Where did you hide it?
Jake:哪啊
Jake: Where?
其他人:那
Others: There.
Tasha:你怎么
Tasha: How did you...
Tasha:被你发现了
Tasha: get discovered?
Jake:哎呀不好意思不好意思
Jake: Oh, sorry, sorry.
Shure: 不好找你就不
Shure: If it's hard to find, don't...
Jake:哈哈没有没有不好意思不好意思
Jake: Haha, no, no, sorry, sorry.
Jake:我以为这是个桌子
Jake: I thought it was a table.
Jake:哈哈不好意思
Jake: Haha, sorry.
Jake:哈哈在在哪在哪啊在哪
Jake: Haha, where is it, where is it?
其他人:我告诉你都找不着
Others: Even if I tell you, you won't find it.
其他人:那那就完蛋了
Others: Then it's over.
Alice:藏这吧
Alice: Hide it here.
Jake:我靠这你确实确实
Jake: Whoa, you really...
Jake:我真以为这个桌子
Jake: I really thought it was a table.
Tasha:这个位置要藏几个啊
Tasha: How many should be hidden here?
Jake:因为原来这有个桌子
Jake: Because there used to be a table here.
Tasha:这个人已经藏了一个了
Tasha: This person already hid one.
Lucia:啊
Lucia: Ah.
Lucia:那是已经藏了一个的吗
Lucia: Is it already hidden?
其他人:藏在这个里面能看到吗
Others: If it's hidden in here, can you see it?
Lucia:好吧哎
Lucia: Alright, hey
Lucia:这不好像不是
Lucia: This doesn't seem right
Lucia:这是标签
Lucia: This is a label
其他人:哎呦我靠
Others: Oh my god
其他人:真看不到你怎么拿出来
Others: Really can't see how you got it out
其他人：你怎么拿出来我想问你
Others: How did you take it out, I want to ask you
Alice:这是贴的
Alice: It's stuck on
Shure: 对啊就有点太暖了
Shure: Yeah, it's a bit too warm
Jake:对对对这个破坏道具了
Jake: Yeah, yeah, this ruins the prop
其他人:不都全傻的吗
Others: Aren't they all fools?
Jake:哎不就
Jake: Hey, isn't it just...
Lucia:哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Shure: 哦这里
Shure: Oh, here
Tasha:这是一个隐藏爆款
Tasha: This is a hidden hit
其他人:我靠确实
Others: Whoa, it really is
Jake:这又是哪啊
Jake: Where is this again?
Jake:那里哈哈哈
Jake: There, haha
Lucia:那里面哈哈哈
Lucia: Inside there, haha
Jake:哦这个里边
Jake: Oh, inside here
其他人:可以直接藏厕所垃圾桶塞
Others: You can just hide it in the toilet trash can
Tasha: 这这还可以再赛一个
Tasha: This, this can fit another one
Shure: 这塞我怕取不出来啊
Shure: If we stuff it, I'm afraid we can't get it out